&gt;&gt; So these two equations give us two different ways of expressing the exact
same curve. But considering this one with the parentheses might not look quite
as pretty as this other one, why would we ever want to use the second form?
Well, from it we can actually find out some information about the curve before
we even graph it. If I label this first form of the equation 1 and this second
form of the equation 2, then what does equation 2 automatically tell us about
that we can't see right off the bat with equation 1? Thinking about the curve
that it graphs, this parabola over here, can we learn very quickly about the
maximum or minimum, about the x-intercepts, or about the y-intercept from
equation 2?